welcome back everybody to another
episode of the h3 podcast live every
Tuesday and Friday at twitch.tv for
Sluss h3h3 productions here with yours
truly
ela kleiner aka what up big pimp this is
what I'm big pants this episode is
sponsored by seat geek which subs like
you
and of course h3h3 shop calm that's us
more about that later today on the show
we have got topics for days our lead
story is about Felix
aka PewDiePie dropping the N bomb and
basically and we're gonna we're gonna
try to tear that apart and get to the
heart of it and we have a we have a
surprise guest callin to get their take
it's a black guy because that you know
often you sit around and you circle jerk
a bunch of white people and it's like
well let's actually ask someone who may
you may actually have been affected by
this mm-hmm so we're gonna actually ask
a black guy introducing an a new segment
incidentally called ask a black man look
I yeah sounds like a joke but it's Syria
like it's a there's value there there's
value there like the name is funny
because it's just so obscene but like
there's value there we were just you
know I've never even had a black guest
in here that's a valuable perspective
okay we're also going to be talking
about the lawsuit settlement which is
finally over signed it's done of course
it wasn't free of some absolute booths
by your boy Matt Haas is we could
finally talk about another sided over we
are going to be talking about our
charity which is now at 220 thousand you
guys are you freaking kidding me
you got that right
we may just fast went 220 that's crazy
we may actually hit a quarter million
dollars on that now all the amazing
items you can win there the Raffles are
still available is closing dan do we end
up extending it until like Monday so in
we're gonna pick the winners on twos our
way don't we think in the winners Dan oh
we have to make up our mind yeah it was
supposed to end today but we're thinking
to extend it a few more days well when
are we picking the winners on Friday
whenever it ends yeah I think our plan
was on Friday the original plan was to
announce winners Friday but if we extend
it to the end of this week then we would
probably announce the winners the
following week so maybe we will extend
it through the rest of the weekend and
announce the winners a week from today
on Tuesday so one week from today we're
gonna announce all the winners are the
raffles you guys could win all kinds of
great prizes let's see if we can get
that to a quarter of a million dollars
because that is just gonna make me cream
dream and we've got to watch some videos
because it is top of the week so we've
got a lot to get to next Friday we have
Eric and Jack Jack film and Eric from
common etiquette coming on to get drunk
and shoot the dang crap here's exciting
dunkey video game donkey and his
girlfriend Leia the incredible power
couple is coming to LA soon and I
freaking got him in here to do a podcast
with us I cannot wait all these smokes I
love them both of them love it Leia is
so cute and their vote is the best they
they're Saints oh yeah
Jason makes the best videos and frankly
I've never even understood his creative
process yeah so I will I love to just
get him in here and pick his brain but
beyond that he's he's such they're both
such genuinely nice incredible people
I'm really excited there's some of my
favorite people on YouTube without a
doubt so very much looking forward to
that I'm sure you guys are too he's
probably our most requested guest right
now yeah
and sadly ela is leaving tomorrow for
Israel for two weeks we touched on that
briefly in our previous episode she's
having some family stuff so she's gonna
be gone for two weeks and I am gonna be
absolutely [ __ ] I'm here for two weeks
by myself
oh god we've never done this before I
don't know if I'm gonna lose weight or
game wish
lose weight but via starvation we are
not having clean dishes yet clean dishes
or or Michael Andre oh my God my lungi
is [ __ ] that's for sure there's not a
debate on that all right well anyway
that's what to expect thank you you guys
everyone for joining us and being here
with us it's a it's a joy privilege and
honor to have you have us be part of
your week so we love and appreciate you
for that that being said let's talk
about race let's lighten it up this is
always tough to talk about we're gonna
talk about Felix dropping the N bomb god
it's so hard to talk about this yeah it
is it's just tough it's not fun stuff I
think the one of the problems is like I
look nobody's as antisocial but you know
what let me just show you guys the clip
for those of you the five of you who
haven't already seen it what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] jeez oh my god
sorry but what the [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't mean that any better so
yeah he dropped uh he dropped the N bomb
and he dropped it pretty hard not like
yeah it wasn't like um it wasn't like a
tomahawk TAC tactical missile it was
more of just like a Hiroshima he dropped
it with that hard yard that colonial you
know eighteen sixties er and he said it
in anger he is an insult I mean it's
pretty much worst-case scenario you know
when they drop nuclear bombs and and the
people out on the street have like
shadows left over and printed on the
sidewalk it's like that
does that make sense that analogy it was
a hard one I agree yeah it's uh it
stopped the way did it is probably the
worst way you could use that word yeah
other than actually calling someone just
like to a black eyespace saying that
yeah yeah it's pretty much the worst
case scenario here so yeah I don't know
like as I was saying before well let me
just let me just continue on cuz
basically I had this whole conversation
planned out but this morning because it
basically two days passed and he didn't
say anything on Twitter about it on
YouTube about it Hyup look re uploaded
one video about stream fails which was a
little bit a little bit of irony there
for him certainly wasn't lost on him I'm
sure so this morning he posted an
apology which kind of changes his whole
conversations I'd like to now play that
for you guys
[Music]
no one on trending that's that what
that's um that's nice of YouTube to do
that hello I am wanted to make a
statement on what I said in my previous
live stream you probably won't believe
me when I say this but whenever I go
online and I got in earlier so easy
cPanel and quit I am at max volume well
then Felix needs to learn that it makes
his video I guess is there no way to
turn it up let me see what I can do
crank it pretty ahead and play it again
which that I did I always find it
extremely immature and stupid and I hate
how I now personally fed into that part
of gaming as well it was something that
I said in the heat of the moment I said
the worst word I could possibly think of
and it just sort of slipped out and I'm
not gonna make any excuses to why it
didn't because there are no excuses for
it I'm disappointed in myself because it
seems like I've learned nothing from all
these past controversies and it's not
that I think I can say or do whatever I
want and get away with it that's not it
at all
I'm just an idiot but that doesn't
make what I said or how I said it okay
it was not okay I'm really sorry if I
offended hurt or disappointed anyone
with all of this being in the position I
am I should know better I know I can
keep messin up like this and I owe it to
my audience and to myself to do better
than this because I know I'm better than
this I really want to improve myself
and better myself not just for me but
for anyone that looks up to me or anyone
that's influenced by me and that's how I
want to move forward away from this
that's all I had to say thank you for
watching all right so what you what you
get is I mean refreshing in that it's
pretty sincere
yeah pretty owning up to to what he did
but the question is like um I don't know
when I first saw that I was I was pretty
shocked I'm like dude come on man you
know like this kind of [ __ ] really
reflects poorly on all of us and it
wasn't that long ago that all of us came
out and rallied against him you know
against them I mean in support of them
yeah and against the media who's now
basically given all the ammo in the
world to be like look at all these
pieces of [ __ ] you know
so methoxy really sucks
I don't think Felix is a racist person
but god damn he really kind of just was
really comfortable using that word that
really just kind of hmm
like you're reaching for all these words
right you're like oh let me just like a
little and bump or yeah I mean I know
this is a point a lot of people say but
it certainly seems like that's not the
first time he's used that word in that
context and look if you joke around with
your friends privately we've all you
said we say offensive things probably
we're talking with our friends cuz we
all find a fire for one reason or other
but goddamn doubt your [ __ ] your
freakin life streaming damn mm-hmm it
really it really I was I wasn't like
angry I was more like disappointed like
damn dog really
after all they surely because coming off
of their life story right that was so
big and their ad pocalypse which was you
know I'm not blaming him for that
I park loosely Camus Awards but it was
probably all related to him it didn't
help the whole climate of everything so
coming off of that to do that is pretty
nuts right I'm obviously it's a it's a
mistake and livestreaming is always a
risk you don't know I'll tell you this
why this podcast freaks me out dude I'm
just waiting because everyone's you know
people do dumb [ __ ] and you say
something you don't necessarily mean and
who knows like it's your live streaming
and it's their the moment you say
something right someone's got it
recorded yes even if you're gonna you
know so obviously yeah it's it's a tough
situation it sucks and I'm glad that he
did apologize and like he said there's
no excuses this time and see I can't
defend him it's completely indefensible
this time yeah yeah man he really just
dropped the end bomb like straight up
and the way he used it was just awful
you know and look there's different ways
to use the n-word like I dubs used it
okay and first of all there I understand
people who would criticize idubbbz and
say that's [ __ ] up the way you use it
but at least in idubbbz there's there's
context he did it as a point to make a
joke to make a parody of Tana mangu who
in the past had dropped and bombs and
then tweeted at him saying oh how dare
you use racial slurs yeah and so the way
he did it was very specific and very
smart and and sense of like those two it
it was just dropping it for no
exactly it was very rhetorical and very
smart the way he use it whether you and
people who are offended it's certainly a
defensible because it's still an
offensive word but in this case there's
no there's no context there's no and it
sucks too because the first time
PewDiePie got in trouble it was I mean
in my opinion it was a bunch of crap
that's just total crap
yeah and afterwards he made he made a
video not that long ago like after
Charlotte Charlotte Charlotte feller
he's like look I don't want to be
associated with these people
yeah so let me just say publicly and he
was doing all he was doing good you know
he was making progress and then he just
drops a freakin n bomb and it's just
disappointing dude you know I'll say
this too it's important to bear mine and
keep keep it all in perspective you're
like as either was saying it's a live
stream [ __ ] can happen doesn't make him
a horrible person or a racist it's not
the same as going and beating up a black
guy and burning across on someone's lawn
yeah it's not like we just watched him
do an act of race yeah he didn't just
like you know but I think it the real
thing is just the disappointment because
yeah he we've all learned through him
know this [ __ ] can backfire and hurt all
of us and how I mean it's like when we
first made videos when we were small
they had no consequence like right I'd
say anything doing anything no one was
even watching yeah both them the more
audience you have and the bigger you get
there really are consequences to doing
and if you think of yourself as an idol
or not some people are looking up to you
and you do have to accept the
responsibility that comes with it and
you know I think generally Peter has a
younger audience who are impressionable
and on the internet it's very fun and
edgy cold to say like horrible racist
shocking things I don't these I wouldn't
say these people are homophobic or
racist or anything but it's like in
fashion to be shocking in a in an anti
social justice warrior and so I think
he's feeding into that which is
something and let
and this is something interesting to
talk about too is like sometimes
nobody's more anti social justice were
than me sometimes though it's actually
okay to be offended and we need to
actually acknowledge that distinction
right and this is part of the reasons
why this cult of outrage that I'm always
criticizing has muddied the water so bad
because everybody's moral compass is so
[ __ ] up that you feel like you're
either offended by everything or not
offended by everything but it's
sometimes okay to be offended yeah and
I've seen a lot of people who are saying
like it's offensive that PewDiePie used
that word a lot of people are just
giving them a straight up past because
you know it's just a word and why do we
give word that much power but it
shouldn't make you a social justice
warrior if you think that people
shouldn't just walk around dropping end
bumps that's ridiculous I'm learning
about how complicated that and word
issue is because I'm from Israel and I
think in Israel people don't really you
know don't even think about it's not
really a thing there so you may hear but
you may hear it in like hip-hop or if
you listen to music but it's not a
debate oh yeah you know so I'm I'm
learning about how complicated it is and
it really is complicated because it it's
I don't know the history behind it is
terrible yes and if the people were
affected by think that people shouldn't
use that word then they have the right
probably to get that right so I see I
understand both arguments like some
people are saying it's just a word and I
understand where they're coming from
because you didn't just see him do
something like an act of racism I don't
I don't guy yeah I don't think is racist
yeah but at the same time work hard
award is it is a certain award that is
not any other word right one of the
questions I have for laters is it just
white people getting offended by this do
black people even care about this I want
to get into that later when we call up
our guest but um
I don't know he basically I think it's
gross
yeah on a personal level I think it's
gross it's irresponsible and it's it's
not cool I mean he's he's he's 27 years
old at this point he should know better
than then and beyond that he's free
computed by his the biggest youtuber he
represents all of us it needs to be more
responsible especially after we all
stuck our necks out to defend him
disappointed is how I would describe my
feelings on that one so anyway that's
that's pretty much my my opinion on it
but then the story developed there's a
whole interesting thing that happen
we're basically the developer of one of
these video games tweeted like [ __ ] this
guy PewDiePie I'm gonna start DMC aying
all of his let's plays to our video game
white guy by the way the developer of
one of the games that it was playing
I've got the hole I've got the hole
tweet thread here it's and and this is
sparked a whole debate that I'd like to
get into here listen let's read this so
this dude here we're filing we're
finally at the MCA takedown PewDiePie's
fire watch content and any future can't
boast Santo Games
so he's retaliating against his
perceived racism by filing a legal
notice yeah to remove his videos it
seems a little it's weird to me and also
he's like the way he's tweeting about it
like he's making a grandstand yeah he's
making like a moral like high ground
yeah here here's this whole rant this is
a bit of leeway you have with the
internet when you wake up every day and
make video games there's also a break
you boy I am sick of this child getting
more and more chances to make money off
of what we make he's worse than a
closeted races he's a propagator of
despicable garbage that does real damage
to the culture around this industry I
heard other developers and we'll be
reaching out to folks much larger than
us to cut him off from the content that
has made him a millionaire furthermore
were complicit I've made money off of
the 5.7 million views that video has an
that's something for us to think about
lastly I love streamers I watched them
daily and sent over 3000 keys to
professional and amateur streamers okay
well it's a look I it's a little petty
it's a little ridiculous it's like good
yeah as he as he acknowledged himself
you've made money from it to you you
have why is it about money all of a
sudden like I'm sick and tired of this
kid making money off of our game you're
making money to him to play their games
you know that it's just a little weird
that timing on this word it's like I
enjoyed him making my game popular but
now that I have the luxury of that video
being you know however old it is and
people not watching it anymore
I'm gonna try to [ __ ] him over and then
the other thing is that I feel like DMCA
takedown is not for this purpose right
that is a hold like if you you don't
want people to play your game and you're
gonna allow it or you don't exactly if
you'd assistant like people will be
playing it all kinds of people rate
racist people can play it too hey I'm
not saying the beautifies races but any
consistent dude a few DMCA felix's video
then you need to basically remove anyone
from playing your game it doesn't matter
what their political point of view is
you let people play your game or you
don't you can't pick and choose because
the DMCA is a legal document it's not
something that you're supposed to just
file at the whim of if you like that
person or not if you like the content or
not it's a legal document that says is
this fair use or is it not and you're
not talking about fair use you're
talking about having a vendetta against
a person so are you gonna are you going
to tell everybody they can't play your
game this is kind of a shitty possibly
illegal thing to do and your sister I
don't know if it's legal or illegal but
that the way I see it this is an abuse
of the DMCA that seems like I do it
that's how I see it I think there's no
logic here if you're not gonna either
allow it or not I don't and if you're
gonna allow people to play your game you
gotta expect that you're not gonna like
everyone who's gonna play your game
no racists are allowed to play my game
and it and also it's like if
his races and he said that while playing
your game no one is relating your game
to what he said like I don't it's
revenge he's pissed off and he's taking
revenge which is not what that system is
for now my question is is it legal yeah
is is playing someone's video game fair
use I don't actually know the question
to that because that's different than
what we went through we were talking
about criticism using somebody's video
for criticism and commentary these guys
are playing a video game I don't believe
that any that's ever gone to court and
been decided on by a judge it's kind of
this agreement between developers and
youtubers or gamers saying you know you
can use this for content and it promotes
us it's symbiotic so let's not even go
there yeah I mean there has been some
cases like Nintendo for example who just
decided one day that they don't want
other people playing their games and
making the money from it so they set up
an agreement with YouTube where Nintendo
gets like 50% or all revenue
automatically claimed from Nintendo
games and people just stop playing
Nintendo games on YouTube it's kind of
an insane thing to do yeah and the way I
see it is I think people in general
should lean towards allowing stuff and
like let's play such a huge shine right
now if people didn't let people play
their game this whole genre was with die
gaming yeah their YouTube gaming is made
this whole freaking industry blow up and
it's it's great I mean I I'm not I don't
even watch it but I don't I think it's
great why not allow it so you think
minecraft would be worth like whatever
billions of dollars it was without
allowing people to use it on YouTube and
let them monetize it my my opinion is it
fair use it I think it probably is and
here's why I because a big thing of fair
use is market harm which means art is
the person stealing basically money that
otherwise would have been yours right
like if Louis Vuitton if someone is
making a fake Louis Vuitton and selling
it that's that's market harm because
you're actually selling an actual fake
one instead of the orig
right but in this case if you watch
Felix playing a game and then you feel
like playing it you're gonna go and buy
the game there's a counter argument that
says if you play through the whole game
people are gonna watch you play it
instead of buying the game like what the
game is meant to be played right and if
you wanna play you still have to buy it
to play exactly and that's the
difference between a movie and a video
game
yeah is that you have to buy it to play
it to get the full experience you know I
do think it's fair use because as ela
said the mark on the whole there's no
way first of all there's no way to
measure it but if you could you would
see own probably a hundred cent of the
time that people are gonna buy the game
way more as a result of you playing it
online so there's that then there's the
other part that says is it
transformative that's actually the most
important question when it comes to fair
use along with the one that you pose is
it transformative I think it is I mean
absolutely I mean I don't think it's
even debatable really I mean people are
watching for for PewDiePie in this case
to play the game they could watch
anybody play but they decide to watch
him because they like what he adds to it
do you think that anyone would watch
asile mean okay
sure maybe it does exist but what do you
think this would be extremely popular do
you think a video of someone silently
playing through this guy's game would
get 6 million views yeah it's tough it's
it's no is my answer because it's very
personal into you yeah exactly so I do
think that it is probably fair use even
though there's never been a definitive
decision by a judge as far as I'm aware
so I think this guy is kind of and again
this guy's muttering muddying the water
he's making he's really [ __ ] this up
this question because he's taking like
um he's taking it too far
he's muddy in the water it's like it's
like let's end PewDiePie his career I'm
gonna talk to other game developers yes
and ask them also to take down the video
and and and he's bending his moral that
the kind of the moral compass of saying
like it's okay to take retribution and
possibly like he's opening such a can of
worms yeah and that's just totally fine
with him and he's tweeting about it
which makes me think that he just wanted
a piece of the drama he does he left it
up look it's probably the most like
tweet by far seventeen thousand likes
I've everyone's saying yeah [ __ ] that
who haven't thought it through they just
want revenge
but I think this guy is actually kind of
a piece of [ __ ] you think I don't know
him I know maybe just based on this
twist maybe he's a fine person but like
dude I don't know man this is not this
is not cool like it's a whole can of
worms you can't you can't approach like
that for all the reasons we've discussed
so I thought this was kind of an
interesting conversation I'm just like
what is going on here is it legal is it
fair use I don't know so that all being
said last time you were right on time
about to call our guest up last time
Felix was making Nazi jokes okay and I'm
I'm a Jewish person so I felt extremely
um trying to pull his number up yeah I
felt extremely qualified one sec here I
felt extremely qualified to address it
and now we're talking about using the
n-word that's not a word that affects me
personally so I do think that instead of
just being a bunch of white people in
here circle jerking about something that
we really don't have any any relevant
issues to take with it that we should
probably get the input of a black person
and see what they think so with that
being said let's have our first segment
of roll it Dan
[Music]
so I'm calling up our boy here hopefully
he answers nice to have you on dude it's
good man so we're talking about the
petabytes PewDiePie thing I was just
telling everybody about how you got
bamboozled about a month ago what
happened I'm curious about the email
well anyway let's get to the issue at
hand here so as I was saying we were all
talking about Felix's use of the n-word
and the point is like we're all a bunch
of white people and I feel like we can
talk about it but we're not really
personally we don't have a personal
stake in it and we can't say that we're
affected by it so I guess I want to ask
you were you offended by what Felix said
you know
I think it's worth saying obviously
people in the world just like coming out
here you know upon their racial profile
you know so you don't when you first saw
that other hurricane just what we need
yeah I think I think a lot of us shared
that just generally shocked like I mean
just yeah
and now a lot of the counter-arguments
I've been seeing a lot of people saying
stuff like it's just a word don't give
it power or something like when people
are playing video games they're just
looking for the worst most insulting
word to find but they don't mean it one
actual comment I saw in a video was dude
he just got pissed at a game and called
someone an n-word but he wrote it out is
it really that big of a deal like how
would you respond to those counterpoints
probably mostly being made by white
people to sit back and label it as it
being just a word you know what I mean
like you can't like okay like for
example
I sit back and I play video games or
should I have to goddamn fool and stuff
you know I mean you know I would never
if I'm playing right you know like a
Mexican person or like a Hispanic person
depending like a game of madden right I
would never come out and be on Sonic so
I would never come out and be a bumpin
insulting all right and so do you think
like in general do you think people are
more offended by this you know yeah yeah
and so I've seen a lot of people saying
stuff like you know it's take it's good
to take the power away from the word so
like Felix it shouldn't have that much
power shouldn't have that it's taking
the power away like what are your
thoughts and people like oh it's good he
said that it takes the power away from
the word and we shouldn't give words
that much power is it like I've seen a
lot of people countering
by saying it's good that Felix said it
because it takes power away from the
word and we shouldn't give words that
much power what are your thoughts about
that you know it's a racist [ __ ] word
the racial word and have a long history
behind it you know what I mean
and there's no such thing well and these
for me like there's no such thing as
saying oh well giving power behind all
right so and then and then kind of a
follow-up like are you familiar with
idubbbz and how he made this video using
the word you know
okay so that was we'll browse that and
so you saw his apology video what did
you think about it you know that's not
me just coming out and blowing smoke up
his ass or anything like that you know
like I said to be like you know my mom
we always you know you know like we were
we're always really good at you know
reading between the lines and stuff and
knowing people are bullshitting like
I've seen that video and I felt like he
was centrally and genuinely honestly
right sorry I really did you know what I
mean and like you know I felt it I felt
like a heartfelt a [ __ ] apology and I
- I mean I know Felix like personally
and I also I mean I could see right
after he did it he saw he's like [ __ ] I
can't believe I did that and I and I do
think that the apology was was super
genuine - I'm sure he's feeling like a
total piece of [ __ ] right now
well good that was awesome man thanks
for calling in appreciate it
eat that [ __ ] four four five let me put
a link in the description Brian
appreciate you god bless you dude thanks
for going we finally collabed for real
hey I'll talk to you buddy
thanks man that was Doug Brian yeah that
was cool yeah I like his take on it
he's it's refreshing I mean like he's
real about it obviously and I do think
it's important to acknowledge like he's
not he doesn't represent every black
person of course there's one guy he's
one guy but anyway what can't one more
can you say that was no he can also take
callers and get all this take some calls
here yeah
that's here I love that guys cello man
he's he's hilarious I stand by what do
we got let's take a call from Debbie
Jamal
Debbie talk to me what's good hey I had
a coach and he got in here Dan god damn
it Dan Ian this is it in the interns
fault is it the speaker not hang with us
Debbie no problem okay there you are I
hear you oh yeah yeah sure so I had a
quick question for you guys yes so when
it comes to the Felix situation do you
guys feel pressured to weigh in on these
kinds of issues and how do you feel with
having to take a stance on such a touchy
issue with the large and potentially
sensitive audience thanks for the
question appreciate you thank prom yeah
it's rough man I don't it's heart it's
always hard for anyone to talk about
this stuff because it's so polarized and
it's so you have to walk on eggshells
because and especially the show being
live right you have to be super careful
about what you say so nothing you know
but in this case
look I'm just saying how I feel my
opinion on these kinds of conversations
especially when it's live it's like I'm
I'm just gonna be honest
mm-hmm I'm just gonna say what I feel
and if somebody wants to hold that
against me then that's just who I am
okay just got to be honest do I feel
pressure to talk about this stuff I mean
well our fans certainly a lot of times
we'll will put a lot of pressure that
one way or the other
but usually you do what you feel like
that yeah I think sometimes I feel like
there's something interesting to say
about it sometimes I feel like there's
nothing to add and I don't want to get
involved so I mean there's always a
certain amount of pressure but usually
it just comes down to what we feel is
the best way thank you for your question
appreciate you
next up we've got Haley from New Zealand
Haley talk to me tell it was good get
this question across right we're going
to take a little bit so I'm from New
Zealand and I'm not had to receive
educated Americans rights and black
civil rights
I really see choice I'm not ignorant but
it's not part of my culture offering
I could ask for an American and so I've
seen a couple of comments talked about
Felix think I'm Sweden and they're
affecting his understanding about how if
the embalm is right I don't agree with
it but like do you think people come
into the community have an obligation to
not be ignorant that's all of the
offenses that kind of a great great
question thank you so much no problem we
were talking about that and it was a
great question okay so you have someone
like Felix who absolutely 100% does not
get a pass he's practically American the
guy's been on YouTube for ten years he
knows he lives in the UK he knows what's
going on here
he knows the power and behind that word
then on the opposite side of the
spectrum you have someone like ela who
lives and who's grown up in Israel and
doesn't live with or even understand the
context they don't speak English I mean
we do speak English but not the same way
not the same way that like Swedish
people in the part of Europe and he
lives in the UK yeah he's on the
internet like ela genuinely didn't
understand the issue yeah I feel like I
actually learned a lot about it very
recently because Bill Maher said it on
his show by mistake kind of - it was
more of a joke so it was different
wasn't a mistake
yeah it was a joke yeah but everybody
got a lot of [ __ ] for it
and Ice Cube came on his show to talk
about it and confront was powerful it
was very powerful he said that and like
I understand that it's a word but you
know you shouldn't use it visit is what
he said yeah if it doesn't affect you if
you're not involved in it you shouldn't
yeah it's kind of like if you're Italian
and you have your own slang you can use
it but I won't use it because I'm not
one of you so Brett you don't use our
word yeah when you say for some people
it means really terrible stuff yeah I
mean one of the things that you'll
always said to me was like why can they
say it shouldn't be not okay for
everyone to say and it's like well you
know let me [ __ ] give you a whole
years of history that we all grow up
with so I think in some cases you
definitely can get somewhat of a pass if
you're a foreigner like a Chinese person
straight off the boat is not going to
understand they probably hear the N word
thrown around and hip-hop and stuff like
that and they they there's no way they
understand the context they could walk
upright to a black person and say that
say hey n-word and not even know that
they're being offensive because in
hip-hop they use it as a term of
endearment mm-hmm but someone like Felix
does not
he's a 100% liable for what he said in
my opinion given his his background and
and you know whatever so anyway thank
you guys two female callers Hey
yeah those female callers that 90% male
demo get freaked cool
well that was a a wild ride that was
cool I think that was a fruitful good
conversation I felt good about that
thank you to the callers and especially
to Bryant mm-hmm links in the
description to his channel and there's
one more thing I want to talk about here
before we go on break we've got a lot
more show left so if you leave something
terrible will happen to you this is a
curse on you if you leave there's all
these like OCD like super CAS people who
are like I can't stop watching that's
this one you have to share this with 10
people or your courage dude
that's right 100 people shared or you're
cursed
for a thousand years of bad poops it's
usually bad sex
I prefer sloppy poops hundred years
about sloppy poops
the lawsuit is over we were in post
settlement negotiations so we couldn't
talk about it but the documents are
signed sealed and delivered and we are
no longer being sued we are free at last
free at last I am gonna talk about it
and of course it wasn't without some
ridiculous
Matt Goss shenanigans so the first time
we made this offer which is a pretty
standard offer and it might be a very
generous of us yeah to offer him the
terms of we will not suit you for
attorneys fees if you if you pledge not
to appeal the decision because I think
that we were gonna win both of those
frankly if we wanted to stick it out and
so he says first his counters response
was like and it always comes with a
stipulation like you have one day to
decide his first counter response was
like I'll do it but your clients have to
agree never to make videos about me yeah
never talk about me or make a view about
me I don't remember the I think it was
don't make a video about me again don't
use my can't tell you and I can't yeah
and so I'm like like I have no
intentions of making more Matt Haas
videos but what like what the [ __ ] are
you buddy dictating the judge and we
just wind argument like if it's fair use
I'm allowed to use it yeah and I will
use your content yeah he's like okay I
understand you just won this long
drawn-out expensive lawsuit
so I'm will he settle in the terms that
you completely undo the whole point of
this so obviously we're like no I have
no intention making pretty but nope so
we pass and her lawyers like all right
let's sue this [ __ ] and then the next
day the next morning we got another one
and he says okay I've been working on my
client his attorney says he's willing to
accept the terms but you can't discuss
the terms in terms of the settlement
like a [ __ ]
ah you're not you boss did you not get
the memo that you lost and if I can't
discuss the terms it basically opens it
up to like speculation yeah I can never
say anything about it ever again yeah I
imagine us like people ask us any
lawsuit updates and we can't talk about
I can't talk about it and how bad does
that sound no we won
he lost we made the offer an act of
generosity and he accepted it so he made
that offer more like you know what no
we're gonna consume you must go to the
[ __ ] Appeals let's do it and then the
next morning yet again he's like okay I
accept your terms and we were on the
fence at that point like man I don't
know if I want to give it to this guy
because we already made like two good
well efforts to resolve this but you
know it's like it's another year you
know if we were gonna go forward with
suing him and he my feeling yeah it's
another year of and it's a headache and
money a lot of money so we were just a
time stress and look as much as this is
a slam dunk case when you send it to
appeals there's a chance as small as it
may be that it's gonna get a turn maybe
you have a hundred percent chance of
winning but you're dealing with the
stress of thinking there's a chance hey
so we were just like you know what also
the guy doesn't have money so we weren't
gonna get our lawyer fees back yeah but
I don't know if that's clear but he's
he's as far as I can tell not a man with
the money to pay us back a hundred
thousand plus dollars it would be a
symbolic gesture and probably one that
would bankrupt him and as far as I can
tell if his financial situation and so
you know we just were like man this we
consulted with some friends and family
and everyone was just like just end it
we have enough [ __ ] on our plate so it's
over it's all over after this long like
almost two years it's finally over and
I'll tell you what I don't wish a
lawsuit on my worst enemy
Matt Hoss I don't wish it I don't even
wish a lawsuit on Matt Hoss I guess it's
not that bad
if you have nothing to lose and you're
not paying for it then it's a fun free
ride all right anyone else feels like
tone it down starting you can fine
whatever
mm-hmm all right so guys thanks for
watching we've got a bunch a great show
coming up next oh you know I got to
thank our sponsors really fast right see
geek I am a big fan of this platform see
kick see geek is a app that aggregates
tickets to live events from all over the
web to make buying simple
they put a 0 to 100 score on each ticket
to let you know if you're getting a good
deal or a bad one green equals good red
equals bad this is so cool say you're
buying tickets to Dodger Stadium
wherever you can actually on their
website get an actual view like a 360
view I think it is from that seat you
can really see exactly their experience
you're gonna get there's no surprises
where you think you got a good ticket
and it's a shitty one you get to see
where you're sitting it's a really cool
idea an app view from seat lets you see
where you're gonna sit guys go to seat
geek.com
and use the code h3h3 to get $20 off
your first order there's a link in the
description click below to download the
app I think these guys are great I'm a
fan and I think that you guys are gonna
have a great experience using this
website see geek.com use CO 2 H 3 H 3
for $20 off your first order I mean it's
like you know there's a lot of
aggregating sites out there but they're
all freaking basically the evil empire
from Star Wars building a Death Star to
try to destroy the supplant it can I get
a amen amen
alright so thank you to see geek if you
guys are about to go see a show
consider going there and using our
coupon code h3h3 next up i want to thank
our wonderful oh my god i love them
- which subscribers oh my god mark
cosmic just thinking about you know he
was leaving I'm gonna be thinking about
y'all that's weird nope it's not weird
it's beautiful
everyone who subscribes via twitch it
helps us a lot and I love you for it
thank you for doing that
you can do it by it's actually
apparently you get a 50% discount during
the month of September if you want to
subscribe it's only 250 instead of five
dollars or if you have Amazon Prime you
can connect it to twitch and subscribe
for free every month thank you so much
it's free money go to free money calm
slash h3 that's not a real domain don't
go there
and of course sponsored by us h3 h3 shop
comm pick up some shirts that help
support the nation
check it out h3 h3 shop comm we're going
to update some new shirts coming up here
soon to everyone who has bought a shirt
I just want to say we are about to start
printing them the ones we sold were a
pre-sale there's our first time ever
making shirts we had no idea how many to
order and basically if you order too
many it can turn into a kind of a
disaster because you have to pay
fulfillment services to keep it in the
warehouse so we had no idea what to
expect this first one was a pre-order
the next one's when we drop them in like
a week or two are gonna be immediate so
I'm sorry for the delay
to all you guys helping support us over
there they'll be there coming I promise
and in the future they'll be immediately
available so everyone who's chooses to
support us at a street shop calm god
bless you okay we are going to take a
quick break but coming up we have got
great videos great stories lots of
laughs couple gifts and I'm there's a
booth one booth guess which ones the
booth I know so we'll be back in a short
couple of minutes guys don't go away or
there'll be a thousand-year curse on
your family I don't know if it's worth
saying on the record again for the for
the final draft but the main
counterpoint I always hear is it's just
a word and I do think that that's true
to an extent the extent being let's not
ruin his career
mm-hm over this because he's not like an
active racist person but at the same
time
let's not treat it like it's the same
thing of saying you suck mm-hmm cuz it's
not that either I mean the truth is
somewhere in the middle it's just a word
to an extent it's not the same as
shooting of black people because you
hate black people obviously look at that
word 22222 y'all are D [ __ ] holy God
Fupa nation's strong super troopers for
life all right let's move it on you guys
let's let's have some fun now we got
serious listen let's bring it down Ted
Cruz y'all know him you love him this is
the man who ran for president who
coughed up a tonsil stone on his lip and
ate it in a live debate you guys have
seen that clip right it's [ __ ]
horrifying Ted Cruz he's eight tonsils
this [ __ ] is disgusting okay take a look
here folks I can't watch it it's
honestly [ __ ] first look at its face oh
god why is it chunk on his lip and what
does he do well slow down
yeah well anyway get to the point like
yeah oh god I feel nauseous
not even a comedy gag just straighten
awesome nausea ISM so anyway that's Ted
Cruz okay this is a fundamental
Christian guy who ran his platform as a
man of God dude has gone on record
saying that masturbation is a sin
against God and the pornography should
be burned this man on Twitter likes a
post where a god damn of a mom walking
in I heard I actually didn't walk but I
assume a mom walked it on her daughter
getting
bound and she starts masturbating and
watching so what I have to assume is
that it was late at night dude was
having a good old FAQ and he
accidentally I look the editing over
this bowl breaking news monkey covering
his face
should I blur this more or is this
covered enough it's right it's
completely covered right
what I'm a did he not know that like
some public
oh I'm sure it was an accidental like
it's an accidental heart that happens to
me sometimes I'm scrolling or I'm
looking at something and you'll you'll
hit tap the heart yeah but usually
you'll notice right and then unlike not
if you just jerked on now if you just
say jack elated and it's you know 1:00
a.m. the family its asleep he's in his
office the doors closed there's a
flicker of light coming through the
glass door it's frosted so they can't
tell what he's doing in there need to
see it flicker of light he squirts one
out he's relaxed he's sedated he didn't
realize that you know oops I flicked
that that hard one so he goes to bed
peacefully I think there's a chance he
actually it doesn't know that's to me
seems insane that on his official Ted
Cruz he's a u.s. senator
presidential candidate likes pornography
on Twitter huh I think he was supposed
to fab sedation and because it was up
for like five or six hours so he clearly
like went to bed right after liking that
which supports my theory and then he
wake kitty
then he removed it at like 5:00 a.m. or
something so [ __ ] great can we just
talk Elena and let me just make this
clear watching porn and masturbating is
completely fine activity that I
encourage everybody to partake in Ted
Cruz on the other hand is a piece of
[ __ ] who goes out saying that
masturbation is against God and let's
burn dildos and he's out there [ __ ]
watching incest porn like this wouldn't
be a story really if the dude wasn't out
on the soapbox talking about porn is
evil so which is it is the dick in your
hand Ted
in your pants yeah we caught you know
how they say you know you say you were
caught red-handed
he was caught to be handed so anyway
[ __ ] this hypocrite you jerk off like
the rest of us and your [ __ ]
holier-than-thou soap box you piece of
[ __ ] you jerk-off you're sick and God
hates you for it Jesus will not forgive
you for this one Ted that's funny people
can hear and laughing in the background
who's laughing that's big walls killing
it Jesus will not forgive you this time
Ted watch this but and if that's not
enough
watch him reenact a scene from The
Princess Bride for example one of my
favorite scenes what's the context of
this by the way it's just for example
one notice he does this thing where he's
always doing impressions thinks he's
like a thespian or some [ __ ] favorite
scenes is is when Wesley the dread
private Robert just brought into Billy
Crystal and he's dead and Billy Crystal
explains eyes only mostly dude and then
he pumps with this old guy looking at
completely an earnest like what the [ __ ]
bellows that says so why is it you have
that assault worth living for
the press is on his chest a smile and
then he got montoya cuz you see he said
Trula there is nothing better than true
love he's literally reenact together for
the movie to make a point I think he
forgot that's not what he said what he
said was to blade and to blade means to
Bluff so what happened was you were
playing poker and he came in and then
suddenly Carol Kane his wife runs in he
goes laia
his material that's the part that kills
man he's getting laughs he's reenacting
a movie get on with it Ted why don't you
go jerk off to some incest porn you
[ __ ] freak God doesn't love you
anymore
tone it down to stronger anyway love
that story and thank you we she was an
actor yeah well to be an actor you got
to uh [ __ ] little boys that's the thing
too apparently maybes it like that's a
whole thing and all they would write
alright let's get off this Jim Carrey
trippin balls you guys maybe I've seen
this one and spicy it's hot as Brendan
Carrie
everybody's talking about this clip
number 41 on trendy Jim Carrey sounds
off on icons and more at the New York
Fashion Week 2017 II live from the red
carpet yes I've covered a lot of Fashion
Week's this is the first time I've run
in to Jim Carrey wait tell me or is it
sure you're wandering the streets you
need a date to the party with them fine
just you know there's no meaning to any
of this so I I wanted to find the most
meaningless thing that I could find come
to and join and Here I am I mean you
gotta admit it's completely meaningless
well they say they're celebrating icons
inside British icons boy that is just
the absolute lowest aiming you know
possibility that we could come up with
it's like icons I'm too a little torn on
this clip because I want him well he it
goes on and on I know everyone's like
saying he's like this [ __ ] for doing and
sticking it to the icons but it's like a
little - I'm 14 and this is deep he's
also like objectively looking from her
angle he's just gone up to this chrome
be like everything you care about
[ __ ] sucks
and his pointless yeah although
apparently I heard that she set him off
by being like are you looking for a date
or like where's your girlfriend cuz
apparently he had a girlfriend who
killed herself recently really so I
don't know what's going on that's really
tasteless if that was them yeah that's
pretty rough so I can understand him
getting pissed at that what do you do
believe in icons
I believe in personalities I don't
believe that you exist but there is the
part where I suspect things we did a
couple dozen icons have the power to
make change to think differently to be
bold to inspire others
artistry you're one of them on the good
foot you shut it down now yeah
personalities I believe that piece flies
beyond personality beyond invention in
disguise beyond the red s that you wear
on your chest that makes bullets bounce
off I believe that it's deep tough
interview you got really dressed up good
love that yeah and I gotta use that more
of my common parlance and there's no you
know we're not here it's all those guys
looking up he's on drugs
I feel like it's a little I don't know
how to feel bad I don't think yeah Oh
Satan Jim Carrey's out there sticking it
to the man yeah I agree
but I can also I'd probably imagine why
he went like Fashion Week I've never
been to it but I know like the fashion
world is so like yeah mother died and
yeah everyone there is superior than
everyone else that's true that may be a
car she's a good point why did he bother
to get into a really nice tuxedo yeah he
could have gone in like you know board
shorts and sandals and a white t-shirt
would they have let him in a Jim Carrey
they would have let his ass in right
yeah I think so so I don't know kind of
interesting though regardless elevant
that's not
that here's the thing it's not our world
a bit of a second delica we don't man
here okay it's a bit though on the other
hand it's a it's a pretty solid bit so
it's funny god bless him out there I
hope you're doing good
I was really sad to hear about his
girlfriend who who who commits suicide
that's flocked and that's stuff Christ
that's got to do a number on your head
eh
it's like damn was I that rough [ __ ]
it's got to get in your head that's got
to be a total mind [ __ ] anyway I don't
think so
get off idiot then right no I don't
think that I don't think that's probably
sad did that happen I don't think is yes
but it's gotta be mixed with a lot of
other complicated emotions your
significant other kills themselves I
don't know what was their relationship
no I actually don't know anything about
it no I was talking like I'm in on a
high level
if your significant other kills
themselves that caught it like being
that significant other diets got it at
least in your head say a lot about you
if it's a serious relationship they
could have been together for two months
yes fossa fall I know you want to find
out can you guys do some research living
limb let's find out the details on that
next up you know what I am so [ __ ]
pissed and over all of these tech
companies leaking my data
Equifax you guys heard about this
probably the one of the largest what did
they they do like credit checks
announced that a hundred and forty three
million us-based users had their
personal information compromised that's
more than half of United States adults
okay attackers reportedly exploited a
vulnerability on Equifax websites to
steal names Social Security numbers
birth dates addresses and in some cases
driver license credit cards for
approximately 200,000 people in CERN
dispute documents
identifying information and
approximately at 182 thousand of those
people were accessed this is life
ruining [ __ ] are you [ __ ] kidding me
to add insult to injury
Equifax waited over a month before
revealing the security had been suffered
do you know how many times these
freaking giant tech companies have
leaked our [ __ ] our phone number our
passwords are law like man these guys
need to be held accountable for this
[ __ ] but it's the problem is that you
agree to use their services or platforms
so you know we need some it something's
got to give here because these services
are becoming you know almost like
utility yeah you know it's like yeah I
use Facebook yeah I use Twitter that it
doesn't it doesn't give you the right to
just share my private information I mean
just recently there was an Instagram
leak where some hackers got a got the
API and were able to steal people's
phone numbers just anyone anyone on
Instagram that's pretty much everybody
just take you okay no thanks thank you
get a email a casual email just so you
know your account was compromised and
now everyone in the world has your phone
number
if you have any questions please email
me at got him
don't care Lal no accountability at
Instagram calm damn what do you got for
us so I looked up the Jim Carrey thing
and I guess so this was actually a
couple years ago in 2015 that it all
went down and basically it was actually
shortly after they broke up which
probably makes it even more painful
because I mean it sound it was mutual or
whatever but he might have like dumped
her and then literally days later she
killed herself
Wow do you having it for information
about how long they were together it
says let's see oh wow and this was in
Sherman Oaks oh this was in LA it
doesn't
say how long they were together let me
know if you find that yeah people were
saying that he's he's being blamed for
being involved in her suicide grab a
ball I'm not sure I want it yeah you can
do your own research on that gumshoes
i'ma stay out of this one but I I
totally understand that like that's got
to be traumatic and I can completely
understand if he's uh unwinding from
that anyway back to Equifax they made a
website where you can check to see if
you were affected but they make you
enroll in their anti-fraud program which
requires you to put in your social
security number and your last name good
luck [ __ ] trusting them with that
information so to find out if you were
hacked you need to type your social
security number and your name to the
people who have no respect for your
privacy can we reflect on the fact that
the largest firm of holding personal
information of almost every American
just got hacked by some [ __ ] goddamn
good check this out if you do choose to
sign up for the credit monitoring
service you must agree to submit any
complaints against Equifax for leaking
your [ __ ] to arbitration you can't
sue on your behalf and you can't join a
class action case or benefit from any
class action settlement then Equifax
agreed to so essentially they're saying
oops sorry sorry that you're about to
become the victim of identity theft
thanks to us we are offering this free
service to protect your identity but by
signing up for this free $10 service you
agreed not to sue us or be a part of any
class-action suit [ __ ] off go bankrupt
let another company take your place that
actually respects people's privacy go
bankrupt I'm angry anyway if you were
affected it
you want to see if you're affected you
can't actually go to trusted part or
what the [ __ ] is this I don't know
trusted premier comm slash eligibility
you can just type in your social
security number name and see if you're
affected sub s we've got another one
here I was meeting to watch this video
for a long time actually mean he that
we're planning on making a full-on
reaction video to this on our main
channel but is this the one you watch o
Queen blaze yeah I heard about this
video by Queen blaze why just why h3
digital blackface I heard it's good my
what oh that's one that Dan was talking
about it's kind of long so I'm not gonna
watch it but I heard it's a good one
so someone made this incredible
animation and we were meaning to make a
diddly dang and reaction video but we
just don't have any time because eel is
leaving tomorrow
so we'll watch it here let's do it
all competition they're on a circuit Oh
what's the name of the guy by the
license give this guy some credit name
is Andy front films
can you guys post that in the comments
I'll put it in the description for
YouTube only took like three months to
make this vision are we no - cell yeah
we're in a prison cell I don't know that
that's how Holocaust museums work I
don't think that
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
that's we good job um like make it look
like Brock
although he did put DJ Khaled sandals
which I don't wear for the record the
details matter
you
it's a real video of Venice Beach that
he transported earth transposed me on
that's so cool
you
Cloudy with a Chance of red bell pepper
okay wonderful
hey goddamn dude front films and that
was amazing he says in the description
I don't endorse anti-semitism by the way
mm-hmm
not sure why he felt compelled to make
that statement but I'm glad he did it
I'm glad that's on the record that was
awesome man thank you so much dude and I
was so good it was a special thing three
months I believe that that was so much
more well I mean that that pretty much
does it I've got a yeah the pretty much
does it for today
so again though that was a wild ride
special thank you to eat that [ __ ] for
chiming in and sharing his opinion thank
you to Ian the intern for not completely
[ __ ] it up today yeah so you know him
that I know evolved to hear from Dan
about how badly [ __ ] up and Sarah are
switcher mm-hmm for switching it up I'll
scream at you later I notice you [ __ ]
out don't think I didn't notice
basically I'm a great boss anyway thank
you everyone for tuning in I hope you
guys had a lot of fun I again as I said
I really appreciate you guys coming and
making us a part of your week it's a
beautiful special thing I don't take it
for granted thank you guys so much for
coming and sharing this Tuesday
afternoon with us
ela is leaving tomorrow I'm sad hopeless
she'll be gone for two weeks we've never
done this before where you staying like
work without me never
the only time we were separated since
like you came here initially was when
you went to Israel and I was moving
right behind you yeah they started
making videos
how long has it been since we've been
like separated must have been like seven
years yeah oh I come back I'm not gonna
survive it's gonna be in like a pile of
dirty baby wife maybe I'll call in the
podcast link oh yes we have the heavy
look all in any way and everybody who
helped support us on tilta fine we're up
to 220 mm super trouper nation is the
strongest army in the world
Jake Paul is back the [ __ ] off and get
dabbed on idiots all right see you guys
on Friday we have jacksFilms and Eric
we're gonna have a lot of fun and guys
we love you yeah so Tata until next time
get dab dog dab on those I love
[Music]